Я просто божеволію в самоізоляції,
хоча минуло лише 2 тижні!
Ну як ви там у самоізоляції?
Я на карантині вже 14 днів... Дідько!
Гадаю, поки всі почуваються не так уже й погано.
Але перебування під замком тривалий час може мати серйозні наслідки.
Люди відчувають смуток, безнадію, пригніченість.
Така ситуація для більшості з нас нова.
Але не для цього парубка.
Він провів 520 днів в ізоляції з п'ятьма іншими чоловіками
в модулі космічного корабля в Москві.
Я поговорила з ним і з професоркою психіатрії про те,
що робити в самоізоляції. І особливо -
як впоратися з відомою серед космонавтів "кабінною лихоманкою".
Найперше потрібно усвідомити, навіщо ви хочете це робити,
яка у вас мотивація. Гадаю, це підходить і до нинішньої ситуації.
Я брав участь в експерименті, щоб зробити свій внесок у дослідження Марсу.
А сьогодні мета наших обмежень - захист сім'ї чи друзів.
Я ненавиджу те, що нам не можна спокійно виходити на вулицю.
Але, можливо, впоратися з цим мені допоможуть думки про те,
заради чого ми це робимо.
Ми всі повинні зрозуміти: зараз саме дистанція - прояв турботи.
Виконуйте якісь свої завдання.
Нехай навіть це буде перегляд фільму чи читання книги.
Розплануйте свій день так, щоб наприкінці дня ви могли сказати собі:
овва, скільки я всього зробив!
Але я маю ще чим зайнятися й завтра.
Я впораюся. Це допомагає жити в сьогоденні.
Не думайте глобально. Заняття конкретною справою відволікає від сумних думок.
"Кабінна лихоманка" - це не психічний розлад.
Якщо чесно, я навіть не ставилася до цього всерйоз.
Але виявляється, це може мати серйозні психічні наслідки.
Рима Стайра досліджувала вплив ізоляції на пацієнтів під час епідемії атипової пневмонії.
Ми з'ясували, що велика частка людей,
які перебували на карантині під час епідемії атипової пневмонії,
потерпали і від депресії. Їм не вистачає контролю над ситуацією.
Їх мучить безсоння.
Що ж, треба знайти собі заняття.
Це прекрасний час, аби набути нових навичок.
Знайдіть нове хобі. Пройдіть навчальний курс.
Врешті-решт зробіть проєкт, який давно хотіли здійснити, але на який раніше не було часу.
Залишайтеся в контакті з близькими.
Спілкуйтеся з членами своєї сім'ї та друзями,
використовуючи сучасні технології.
Це чудова підтримка.
Зараз особливо відчувається командний дух.
В ізоляції нині перебуває так багато людей, що вони не відчувають себе самотніми.
Тобто навіть якщо ти один, ти не один, бо інші теж в ізоляції?
Вірно.
У нас було вісім годин роботи, вісім годин дозвілля і вісім годин сну.
Ми самі собі створили графік.
Думаю, важливо мати рутину, структурувати свій день.
Ви знаєте, чим займатиметеся кожен день.
Рутина допомагає впоратися зі страхом і тривогою.
Я встаю вранці в один і той же час.
Наношу макіяж, навіть якщо мене ніхто не побачить.
Готую собі один і той самий сніданок.
Знаєте, я роблю все це лише для того, щоб створити видимість нормального життя.
Через певний час рутина набридає,
тому час від часу намдоводилося порушувати цю одноманітність,
роблячи деякі дні особливими. Пам'ятаю,
на Гелловін ми вирішили ходити в костюмах цІлий день,
а ввечері ми разом дивилися фільми жахів,
адже був Гелловін, і ми хотіли зробити щось особливе.
Це додало нам енергії, щоб продовжити і місію, і самоізоляцію.
Входячи в модуль, я сказав собі: тепер це мій Всесвіт.
Все, що я не можу зробити зараз, я зроблю через півтора року.
І це теж підходить для нинішньої ситуації.
Чекайте з радістю того моменту, коли все знову стане можливим.
Перебуваючи в ізоляції такий тривалий час, ми були позбавлені певних речей.
Ми не усвідомлювали, що ми за ними сумуємо.
Але коли ви повернетеся до звичного життя
і до вас повернеться багато речей, це буде так круто!
Кілька тижнів тому гуляти і зустрічатися з друзями
було звичною справою в будь-який час.
Я вважала це чимось само собою зрозумілим.
Я впевнена, що тепер цінуватиму маленькі радості більше, ніж раніше,
коли це безумство закінчиться.